Female: ... week in the NBC family.
And here at CNBC,
we want to give our viewers the
chance to learn more about finance,
hoping you understand where
exactly your money is going.
Joining us now in the studio is Sal Khan,
(music)
founder and executive
director of the Khan Academy.
He is also the mind behind dozens
of videos featured on CNBC.com,
and he'll explain financial concepts.
So what exactly are you doing?
What's your initiative?
Sal: Khan Academy itself,
it literally just started with
me trying to tutor cousins,
and I put my videos on
YouTube, and they got popular,
and so I quit my old job,
and I started doing videos on algebra
and calculus and all the rest.
And I even did a few on
economics and finance.
CNBC contacted me and said,
"Hey, we want you to do more of that
"and explain what is a credit default swap
"or what is the difference between
preferred equity and regular equity,
"and what is the present
value of something?"
Female: Is it true anecdotally
that you got letters from bankers
who said that you saved
them from getting fired
so they can learn more
about [unintelligible]
Sal: Yeah, that happened again last week.
I was at a ...
Female: ... confidence-building.
Sal: It is not very confidence-building,
but at least they had that (laughs).
(laughter)
At least they had ...
No, I had someone who worked
in mortgage-backed securities
during the financial crisis.
Male Isn't it that the truth
that people out there who,
people think they know.
They think they're supposed
to know these things,
and most people really don't.
Sal: No.
And what I say is the
more jargon someone uses,
the less likely they actually
know the underpinnings of what.
And so yeah, I mean I think
there are a lot of people
that say the mortgage-backed
security industry
who are signing the documents, getting
them stamped by their rating agency,
Male: Obviously, yeah.
Sal: No one knew what was
going on in the big picture.
Female: Last week, you were talking about
how there is the need for more
understanding and education about ETFs.
How much interest do you see in people
educating themselves about ETFs?
Sal: Yeah, ETF is one of them.
I didn't do a video on that,
but it's one of those things.
A lot of people will say,
Male: They don't really
understand what it is.
Sal: "But how does that it work?
"Is it a mutual fund?
"Is it close-ended?
"Is it open-ended?
"Is it something in between?"
and so that's what I try to do,
is just to break it down,
draw it out, and explain it.
Male: So your site is ad-free?
Khan: It is ad-free.
We're not for-profit,
and so we get the Gates
Foundation, Google have funded us,
and so yeah, kids can
learn algebra without ads.
Male: And the economics
of a cupcake factory.
Sal: And the economics of a cupcake ...
Sal: Yes.
Male: But how do you get the ideas then?
if somebody comes and say,
"I want to open a cup cake factory,
"but i have no idea what the
economics of said factory would be,"
and therefore, you make a video?
Female: What's the [unintelligible]
Sal: Some of those things,
like the cupcake factory,
my old job as an analyst at a hedge fund,
I had another company in mind,
but I just changed their industry
when I talked about
predatory prices and cupcakes
because it seemed much
more benign (laughs)
Male: It's very mysterious.
Male: Very mysterious.
Sal: Very mysterious.
Female: Well, thank
you for coming on, Sal.
Sal: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
Male: khanacademy.org, you have
some crazy classes on here.
Sal: Indeed, yes.
Female: What's the craziest?
Male: Yeah, very cool stuff.
Sal: Photosynthesis, in
case you're interested.
(laughter)
Male: We wouldn't know about that
because we don't have any sunlight.
Sal: No, no.
(laughter)
Male: No skylight here.
Female: I'll get my plants
to watch it (laughs).
Male: Sal, thank you very much.
Sal: Yeah, yeah, thank you.
All right, learning a lot.
Sue: Rockefeller Plaza has been
transformed for the summit,
and that's where we find
Michelle Caruso-Cabrera
along with two leading innovators
(music)
in their respective fields.
Take it away, Michelle.
(music)
Michelle: Here are some of the coolest
and most interesting people
I've met in a really long time
joining me here at Education
Nation down here at 30 Rock.
Nt Etuk is the founder of DimensionU.
This is an educational video
game company that he started.
He used to be at Citigroup,
and he is rolling out a
lot of exciting things.
And Sal Khan joins us as well.
He is the founder of the Khan Academy.
This is an educational video and ...
so not video games but
videos and software company.
Sal: Yes, yes, yeah.
Michelle: You both have the same idea,
which is that you want to
go directly to the customer,
so you're not selling to schools.
You're not selling to
parents necessarily, right?
Nt: Well, actually, we do have a
component that we sell to schools,
and it's been proven ...
well, first of all, we do
multiplayer educational video games,
so imagine Halo minus the violence
but allowing a kid in Seoul, Korea to
play against a kid in New York City
while they're learning math,
literacy, science, history.
And so we started out selling to schools.
We have large portions of New York
City Public Schools, et cetera.
And now, we're going to the consumer side.
Michelle: I guess my
thought was, what I mean,
Nt: Yes.
Michelle: Because historically,
educational video games have been ...
Michelle: ... boring, right?
And textbooks and so are workbooks.
So if you can do video games,
then they're, like, "Hey!"
Michelle: That they really want to play.
Nt: That they want to play.
You can incentivize them to
learn, and it's fantastic.
Michelle: Wow.
Sal: Yeah, it's the same idea.
One thing, we're not selling.
We're not for profit, so that's why
we're a little bit small (laughs).
Michelle: OK.
Sal: But our target is the
students and at any age.
We have six-year-olds.
We have homeschoolers.
We have people using supplement tools ...
Michelle: And they're
getting them where, YouTube?
Or how are they getting the product?
Sal: It's off of YouTube, khanacademy.org.
YouTube, it's just the videos.
Most of our resources are on
making a software platform.
It has a little bit of games in there,
but so students can practice everything
that they might learn in the videos too,
and it goes all the way to calculus.
Nt: Yeah.
Michelle: Does it matter if
it's profit, not for profit?
Does it?
Nt: From my perspective, for profit
is how you keep sustainability going.
I think that there is a
great way to actually make
a tremendous amount of money
while doing good at the same time,
and so that's what we do.
Michelle: How is rollout going?
You are now selling to schools.
Are you getting schools involved?
And is it easier to sell to charter
schools and things like that?
Are they more adaptable as
opposed to public schools
that have a longer purchase cycle?
Sal: Most of our users, we have
2.5 million students a month,
those are mostly just
independently using it,
but we have started pilots.
The Los Altos School District in Silicon
Valley, they're district-wide with it.
They're public school.
They're not a charter school
or anything like that.
We are piloting with some charter
schools, some private schools, public,
and we're just trying to see
how we can use this thing
that's fundamentally
for independent learners
but how we can use it
in the classrooms too.
Michelle: Are either one of you
providing backbone analytics ...
Nt: Yes.
Michelle: ... to the schools so
that you know that it works?
Very, very important.
So how long are the students playing?
What are they getting right and wrong?
But we actually can go even deeper.
We can understand if a student
plays primarily by themselves
or whether they play with others,
so are they a social learner or
are they an individual learner?
And then you know how you can
help by tutoring or whatever else,
so a whole bunch of
analyticals that gets it right.
Michelle: Sal, is there ...?
Sal: Yeah, I know.
The model that we're
trying in the classrooms,
the teachers aren't
giving lectures anymore.
They're not grading homework.
The students are all
working at their own pace,
and the teacher gets a dashboard and
highlights the students that are stuck.
So the teachers not able to do
these one-on-one interventions,
we get the peers to teach each other.
Nt: Yeah, exactly.
Sal: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Michelle: But what about schools
that don't have resources?
Are they less likely to get this stuff?
Nt: From our perspective,
that's one of the reasons why
we went to the consumer side,
much like we're doing a free model ...
Michelle: For the consumer.
Nt: For the consumer side.
Nt: But the kids at home
can get it for free.
Then we actually make money
through micro-transactions,
somewhat like Zynga, et cetera,
so that sort of thing as we roll that out.
It's been very interesting.
Michelle: How about you, Sal?
Sal: Yeah, it's a ...
It's, it's ....
Yeah, we do ...
We ...
I'm sorry if I ...
Michelle: Don't worry about it (laughs).
Don't worry about it.
Should people be hopeful about education?
Is there ...?
Sal: Yes.
Michelle: We've talked so long
about how we've been failing
for years in this country.
Michelle: You're optimistic?
Nt: Very.
Here's the problem.
The problem right now with the innovation
conversation education is it's tiring.
We could have had this
conversation 300 years ago.
Michelle: Yeah.
Nt: What we have is
Google, iPod, iPod, iPad,
all of these sorts of
technology to come in,
and we can get rid of the
traditional distribution structures,
go directly to the kids or
go directly to the teachers
Michelle: A real product
that they want to use.
Male: Yeah.
Sal: Yeah, same thing,
and I just remembered your
question was about technology,
(laughter)
And I think right now, there
is a healthy skepticism
of why do you use
technology in the classroom?
And I think what we're talking about
is now you have a reason to use it.
And once you have a good reason,
it's actually not that expensive anymore.
You have a $300 laptop.
You could use it for
five years at $60 a year.
Michelle: As opposed to ...
And 10 kids could use it.
Michelle: As opposed to
textbooks, which could
be far more expensive.
Sal: Far more, far more expensive.
Michelle: Guys, thank you so much ...
Nt: Thank you.
Michelle: ... for this wonderful
conversation I had with you.
Sal: All right, great.
Tyler, back to you.